Whether you know it or not, you use
layers in every single game of magic you
play. And they often get a bad rep for
being one of the hardest rules in the
game to learn. But I'm here to destroy
that myth and give you an easily
digestible guide to layers so you can
work out even the most complicated of
interactions. I'm also going to teach
you the secret layers jutsu to stop
Magus of the Moon. As always, I'm going
to start at the beginning, build the
foundation, and work towards some more
advanced examples and rules. So, with
that being said, let's jump into it. So,
what are layers even about? The layer
system is the way we order and apply
multiple continuous effects to a board
state.
Wait, so what are continuous effects? As
per rule 611.1,
a continuous effect modifies
characteristics of objects, modifies
control of objects, or affects the
players or the rules of the game for a
fixed or indefinite period. And then
rule 611.2 tells us that a continuous
effect may be generated by the
resolution of a spell or an ability.
Basically, something that changes the
printed information on a card, changes
the controller of something, or changes
the rules of a game that is produced by
a static ability or resolving a spell.
For example, casting giant growth on a
creature and pumping it up plus 3 + 3
until end of turn. That power and
toughness buff is a continuous effect.
The effects making spells cheaper on
Helm of Awakening is a continuous
effect. and winter making players have
smaller hand sizes is also a continuous
effect. Also to clarify, if I or the
rules mention the word object, that
means any thing in the game. The
glossery in the comprehensive rules says
an object is an ability on the stack, a
card, a copy of a card, an emblem, a
token, a spell, or a permanent.
Now, let's jump into what each of the
layers are so we know what to start
looking for. Starting at layer one, we
have copy effects. Examples of this
would include clone or true polymorph.
This layer also includes effects from
mutate and effects that set the
characteristics of a card being played
face down. For example, cyber conversion
turns a creature face down and makes it
a 2 two Cyberman artifact creature.
This first layer effectively defines and
sets what the copyable values are for a
card. This is why when you cast clone,
copying a clone that's a copy of grizzly
bears, your clone will become a grizzly
bear and not a 00 clone, as it's also
the reason why clones don't copy any
buffs or other effects that might have
been applied to the card you're copying.
In layer 2, we have control changing
effects. So things like mind control and
act of treason, anything that would
change the controller of something.
Simple enough. In layer three, we have
text changing effects. Anything that
would change the text on an object.
Probably the most well-known modern
example of this would be Deadpool
trading card. A card that swaps an
entire text box with another creature.
And then there's cards like Witness
Protection and Psychic Paper that can
change the names of cards.
In layer four, we have type changing
effects, an effect that would add,
change, or remove any objects type,
super type, or subtype. Probably the two
most well-known cards for this
particular layer are Magus of the Moon,
which changes all non-basics into
mountains, and Bellow Bard of the
Brambles, which gives your four or
greater mana value, non-equipment,
artifacts, and nonura enchantments, the
creature type, and elemental subtype.
Effectively, you're looking for anything
that would change this part of the card
right here. Any card with changeling
would be another great example.
In layer five, we deal with color
changing effects. For example, the one
on painters servant or the ones on the
Mandland abilities. In layer six, we
have ability adding or removing effects.
Probably the most contentious layer for
a reason we'll discuss later. It's on
this layer where we'll add or remove
abilities from objects. A good example
of this would be dress down or a
chroma's will. This layer also includes
any keyword counters like the ones a
permanent gets from perination.
And finally, we have layer 7, the layer
that deals with power and toughness
changing effects. In this layer, it's
broken down into four sub layers. In
layer 7A, we have effects that define
power and/or toughness through a CDA.
Taggoy or Lord of Extinction are the
classic examples here. Effectively, it's
the layer that defines what the stars
are on a card. In layer 7B, we have
effects that specifically set the power
and toughness of an object. For example,
diminish. Look out for the words base
power and toughness.
In layer 7 C, we have effects that
increase or decrease power and
toughness, for example, giant growth or
toxic deluge. This layer also includes
plus one + one and minus1 minus1
counters. And finally, in layer 7D, we
have effects that swap power and
toughness like the one on inside out.
So that's the seven layers. It's also
worth noting that yes, a single card can
affect multiple layers. For example,
snake form has continuous effects on
layers 6, 5, 4, and 7b.
Now we know what the layers are, it's
time to learn how to apply them. To put
it simply, you take a board state, find
all the continuous effects that are
currently being applied to it via spells
or abilities controlled by all players,
and then you apply them to the board
state in the order of the layers list
from top to bottom. And as per rule
613.5,
the layers are constantly checked and
applied instantly.
It's also important to note that as
you're going down the layers list, once
you apply a layer, it effectively gets
locked in and you can't go back up to
that layer to change something. Think of
the layers like painting on a canvas. We
apply the first layer of paint and then
the second and so on. But once we get to
the sixth layer, we can't then go back
and change something on the fourth
layer. it's already been painted on.
We'll come back to this rule in a bit.
Let's look at a quick basic example.
Let's say we cast Cyberdrive Awakener
while we have a soul ring in play. Once
we resolve Cyberdrive's ability, we've
got some layers to apply. So, in this
case, we start at layer four. Each
noncreature artifact we control becomes
an artifact creature. We then move to
layer six and give our other artifact
creatures flying. And then we move to
layer 7B and set their power and
toughness to 44.
Okay, so that seems easy enough. And
don't forget, this happens instantly.
And if there were any other continuous
effects, we would apply those at the
same time. Again, more on that shortly.
There's two more really important
examples I want to cover. Say I have a
benalish marshall in play. It says other
creatures you control get plus one plus
one. And then my opponent casts a humble
targeting it which says until end of
turn target creature loses all abilities
and has base power and toughness 01.
So again let's see what layers we're
dealing with here. Benolish Marshall
pumps up creatures, so that's layer 7 C.
Humble removes all abilities at layer
six, and sets power and toughness at
layer 7B. Now, we'll apply the layers.
We'll start at layer six and remove all
abilities from Benelish Marshall. Now,
because this effect has removed the
marshall's ability before they could
start to apply it, it gets removed
completely and won't be applied to the
board state. So now all we do is move to
layer 7B and set the marshall to be a
01.
The easiest way to remember this is that
the upper layers can impact the lower
layers, but not the other way around.
Let's look at this classic example
before we move on. What happens when we
have a humility in play that says all
creatures lose all abilities and have
base power and toughness 1 one and then
we play a magus of the moon which says
non-basic lands are mountains.
So first let's see what layers are being
impacted.
We have magus of the moon changing land
types. So that's layer four. We then
have humility removing all abilities
from creatures. That's layer six. And
then we have humility setting creatures
power and toughness to 1 one. So that's
layer 7b. We'll then go to apply the
layers in order. We'll start at layer
four and change non-basic lands into
mountains. We'll then move to layer six
and remove magus of the moon's ability.
And then we'll jump to layer 7B and set
Magus' power and toughness to be 1 one.
Now, here's the kicker. Non-basic lands
will still be mountains.
Now, hold on. Before you jump to the
comments to start typing up a storm and
telling me how wrong and stupid I am,
I'm looking at you, read F10. Let's go
through the rules. Rule 613.6 Six tells
us if an effect starts to apply in one
layer and or sub layer, it will continue
to be applied to the same set of objects
in each other applicable layer and or
sub layers even if the ability
generating the effect is removed during
this process. So this is what I
mentioned before. Once we apply a layer,
it effectively gets locked in and
removing that ability later on, for
example, in layer six won't stop that
ability from applying. Now, Magus'
effect only impacts a single layer. But
this lockedin rule also applies to
abilities that impacts multiple layers.
For example, Kudo, King Among Bears, and
Bellow, Bard of the Brambles. Both of
these cards start applying at layer 4.
So, by the time we get to layer six with
humility and remove their abilities,
Bellow and Kudo will continue to apply
their effects all the way down to layer
7B, where they'll set power and
toughness to their relevant amounts.
Another great example is simply clone.
If we have a clone in play and then
someone casts humility, clone won't
suddenly stop being a copy of something.
This is the same reason as Maggas of the
moon and bellow. Clone's effect starts
applying in layer 1 before it gets
removed in layer six. So, it will
continue to apply. Now, for those of you
wondering, well, how do we stop bellow
or mags of the moon, we first need to
learn about the next two things,
timestamps and dependencies.
Now, if you've learned something thus
far, be sure to give the video a like
and subscribe if you want to see more
content like this. Let's continue. So,
now we know how to apply individual
layers. We simply apply them in order of
the layers list from top to bottom and
the upper layers can impact the lower
layers. But what happens if we have some
abilities interacting on the same layer?
For example, what if I had a Magus of
the Moon in play, which impacts layer 4,
and our opponent had harbrer of the
seas, which also impacts layer 4. Would
non-basic lands be mountains or islands?
which order would we apply these
continuous effects? And this is where
timestamps come into play. As per rule
613.7,
within a layer or sub layer, determining
which order effects are applied in is
usually done using a timestamp system.
An effect with an earlier timestamp is
applied before an effect with a later
time stamp. A time stamp is simply an
invisible marker that keeps track of the
order of continuous effects. Now, just
to clarify, there's three ways that a
continuous effect can be produced. By a
resolution of a spell like giant growth,
the resolution of an ability like the
one on Shven Dragon, or the static
ability of a permanent emblem, or
something similar. Continuous effects
are given timestamps upon the resolution
of the spell or ability generating them
or when the permanent with a continuous
effect enters a zone. Let's quickly go
through an example. I have a grizzly
bear in play. My opponent cast diminish
on it, setting its power and toughness
to 1 one. When this spell resolves, it
gets a time stamp. I then cast almost
perfect, an aura which sets the
enchanted creatures base power and
toughness to 910.
When this aura enters, it gets a later
time stamp. So when we go to apply the
layers, when we get to 7B, we will apply
the power setting effects in time stamp
order, oldest to newest. So we'll set
the bear to be a 1 and then we'll set it
to be a 910. Now, I mentioned before a
couple of ways things get timestamps.
There's a few others you should keep in
mind, too. Counters individually get
timestamps when placed on something.
This is mostly important for ability
counters.
Auras, equipment, and fortification gets
new timestamps each time they become
attached to something.
Permanence get a new time stamp each
time they're turned face up or face
down. And transforming permanents get a
new time stamp each time they transform.
And while I mentioned a permanent gets a
time stamp when it enters a zone, it's
worth pointing out that that means that
permanent will get a new time stamp
anytime it is blinked or flickered,
which can become relevant for the first
example we started this section with. If
I played Maggus of the Moon on my turn
and then my opponent played Harbor of
the Seas on their turn, what would
non-basic lands be? So, we already know
that each of these effects applies on
layer 4, but now we know we apply them
in timestamp order. So because the magus
of the moon entered the battlefield
first, we apply macas first, then the
harbringer, meaning all non-basic lands
will be islands. Two more things we need
to cover about timestamps before we move
on. Firstly, if multiple objects enter a
zone at the same time, we give them
timestamps in appnap order. So the
active player chooses the timestamp
order for everything they control that's
entering. And then the next player in
turn order does the same and so on.
And finally, and this only really
applies to Zoo from Edge of Eternities
and a handful of other effects, if a
continuous effect generated by a static
ability of an object and a continuous
effect generated by a resolving spell or
ability that applies to that object
would receive a time stamp
simultaneously,
such as due to an effect that puts that
object onto the battlefield and sets its
characteristics.
the continuous effect from the object's
own static ability receives an earlier
time stamp.
Basically, all this means is that the
effect bringing the object into play
will apply its abilities last.
The only examples I can think of to
demonstrate this is if Zoo brought back
a changeling, the changeling would give
itself every creature type in layer 4
first, then Zoo would change it to be
just a skeleton. Now, while we generally
apply continuous effects on the same
layer in timestamp order, sometimes this
order is changed due to dependencies.
Let's cover a quick example. On my turn,
I cast March of the Machines, which says
each non-creature artifact is an
artifact creature with power and
toughness equal to its mana value. I
then play Micros Lattis which says all
permanence are artifacts in addition to
their other types. The key thing to call
attention to here is that March of the
Machines and Micros
layer 4. March of the Machines turns
artifacts into creatures and Micros
turns things into artifacts.
So if we applied these effects in
timestamp order, we would have a
situation where only the artifacts in
play when we cast March of the machines
would become creatures and there would
be a number of permanents which are made
into artifacts thanks to microin lattice
that wouldn't be creatures and that's
not right. This is where dependencies
come into play. As per rule 613.8A 8 a
there's a three-step check to see if a
dependency exists. An effect is said to
depend on another if a it's applied in
the same layer and if applicable sub
layer as the other effect B applying the
other would change the text or the
existence of the first effect, what it
applies to or what it does to any of the
things it applies to. and C. Neither
effect is from a characteristic defining
ability or both effects are from
characteristic defining abilities. So
going back to our March of the Machines
Micro Synth Lattice example, both of
these effects apply on the same layer.
Tick March of the Machines would apply
to more permanent if the micro effect
was applied first, i.e. applying the
other would change what it would apply
to. And finally, neither of these
effects are characteristic defining
abilities. So in this case, March of the
Machines is dependent on microynthis.
So in this example, we would ignore
timestamps and microin lattice would be
applied before March of the Machines.
It's worth pointing out that if there
were any other effects to be applied on
this layer, they would be applied in
timestamp order. The easiest way to see
if something is a dependency or not, is
to take your two effects, let's call
them A and B. Apply A to the board state
first, then apply B and see what the
board state looks like. Then undo that
and then apply them in the opposite
order. If A applies to different things
or now doesn't apply at all, A's effect
is dependent on B. Let's look at some
more examples. Blood Moon and Herborg.
If we apply Herborg first, it makes
everything a swamp and then Blood Moon
removes Borg's ability and turns it into
a mountain. If we swap the order, Blood
Moon makes Herborg a mountain, and
Herborg no longer has an ability to
apply. So here we have a case of
applying the other would change the text
or the existence of the first effect. So
in this case is dependent on blood moon.
Another example would be having kende in
play and giving another creature first
strike with kindled fury. If we applied
the effects in time stamp order, the
creature buff with Kindled Fury would
not gain double strike, but applied the
other way around, Kuwende would give
them double strike. For our final
example, I'm going to teach you a secret
jutsu you need to know to stop Magus of
the Moon and Bellow. So, looking at
Magus of the Moon and Bellow, they both
start applying in layer 4. So, we need
an effect that impacts here. Check out
Song of the Dryads, an enchantment that
makes enchanted permanent a colorless
forest. Looking at the layers of this
card, we can see that it applies in
layers 4 and layers 5. Now, one other
rule we need to know that I'll quickly
mention is rule 305.7,
which basically says if a land has its
type set to one or more of the basic
land types, it loses all of its
abilities.
This is why Blood Moon and Magus of the
Moon turn off non-basic land abilities.
So knowing this, when Maggus of the Moon
is enchanted by Song of the Dryads,
they'll lose all of their abilities. So
as we've previously discussed, if an
effect would change the text or
existence of the first, Magus of the
Moon being the first effect, there is a
dependency.
So here, Magus and Bellow would be
dependent on Song of the Dryads. So,
they'll lose all of their abilities
before they can even start to apply.
Of course, you can just destroy them,
turn them into a Cybermen, or make them
a copy of something else. But you know
what they say, the more you know.
Speaking of, I know that when people see
this example, they're immediately going
to ask about Maggus of the Moon and
Imprisoned in the Moon. So, let's go
through this and explain why it's not
the same.
Okay, so Magus applies on layer four.
Imprisoned in the moon applies on layers
five, four, and six. Let's apply the
layers. So to start, we have Maggus
making things mountains and imprisoned
wanting to make Magus a land. So we have
a dependency here. So we'll make Magus a
land. Here's the really important call
out. Making something a land doesn't
inherently remove the permanence rules
text. It's making something a land and
giving it a basic land type which will
do so. So again, imprisoned will make
Magus a land. They will still have their
abilities.
We will then make all non-basic lands
mountains, which will also include
Maggus. But like we've mentioned before,
once an ability starts to apply,
removing it doesn't stop it from
applying. So Magus will continue to be a
non-basic mountain.
We'll then get to layer five and make
Magus of the Moon colorless. And then go
to layer six and remove Magus' intrinsic
tap to add red ability thanks to being a
mountain. And replace that with tap add
a colorless. So the final result is that
all non-basic lands will be mountains
and Magus of the Moon will be a
colorless mountain that can only tap for
colorless. The last thing we need to
mention about dependencies is dependency
loops. Now, in my entire history of
playing Magic, I have never seen a
dependency loop in any of the games I've
played. But all they are is imagine you
have three effects A, B, and C. And each
of these effects depends on each other.
This is where a dependency loop forms.
Rule 613.8C 8 C tells us that if a loop
forms, we simply apply the effects in
timestamp order. Now, I'm going to link
to some resources below if you want to
dive further into dependency loops, but
as I've mentioned, it's unlikely you'll
come across them in a real game. Okay,
final thing we need to cover is rule
613.11,
which tells us about effects that aren't
included on the seven layers. things
that change the rules of the game
instead of impacting individual objects.
Effects that change players hand sizes
or forcing creatures to attack. These
are applied after everything else and
are applied in timestamp order.
All right, this is it. Final test time.
I control null rod, new rock,
transmuter, and March of the machines. I
activate New Rock Transmuter's second
ability, targeting the Null Rod after
the ability resolves. What does Null Rod
look like?
I'll leave the answer in the pinned
comment below as this video has gone on
long enough. Now, if you have any
questions, let me know in the comments
below. Be sure to like the video if you
learned something and subscribe because
if you don't, Wizards won't release the
secret eighth layer. Thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next one.